Oh, Emma. Look, we're really happy with how you've been performing thus far...
...and you've definitely stepped up from last month.
I think you were seen an orange, but I think we should move that up to green, you deserve it.
Great. Thank you.
Emma, we're really happy with how you've been meeting your objectives.
It's aligning perfectly with the organizational values.
You're a team worker.
You're honest.
You're quite excellent at what you're doing.
So, thus far we're really happy with how you've been.
Do you have any questions for where we're headed...
...and the role that you've been doing so far?
No, not at the moment.
I mean, I keep it up to date with my notes on there, about the thing that I'm doing...
...and obviously, I can see your replies on the system anyway.
So, everything that I need to know month by month is pretty much there already.
I want to also discuss your development plan...
...and how you think you're traveling with that so far.
In regard to other skills, other areas that you like to learn more about,...
...can you tell me anything about that?
If I'm honest, I'd quite like to be a bit better on Excel...
...so if you've got any courses on that, that'd be really helpful to me.
Emma, we really want to focus on your career progression here at the company...
...so, any way we can help your work, we're more than happy to do so.